MARC TOBIAS KUNISCH:
Developers have
been creating Instant
Apps for over a year
now, enabling users to enjoy
their apps by simply tapping
a link or pressing a
button in the Play Store
instead of installing
the entire app.
But we didn't want
to stop there.
Games are a big part of the
user experience on phones.
For this reason, we've extended
the Instant App technology
to games.
Welcome to Google Play
Instant, where apps and games
can be played instantly.
You might have seen the UX
best practices for Instant Apps
that we published last year on
the Android Developers Channel.
If you haven't yet,
they're worth checking out.
The link is in the
video description below.
Don't worry.
I'll be here when you come back.
But since games are a
little different than apps,
I'd like to talk a bit
about the user experience
specifically for games
on Google Play Instant.
There are many different
ways that users can access
a game without installing it.
Users may be coming from
an ad, a link on a website,
a message from a friend, the
Play Games app, Google Search
results, or the Try Now
button on the Play Store.
Consider what you want your
gaming experience and Google
Play Instant to accomplish.
Do you want it to be
a standalone game that
is completely instant?
Or can you make the
first level of your game
available to be accessed
instantly, allowing users
to try out your game?
Developers have created
this sort of companion
to their existing games.
This experience creates
excitement with your gamers
by showing off the most
exciting parts of a game
before installation.
There are plenty of exciting
options to choose from.
Think about which route you
want to take, and be deliberate
when building out your
Instant experience.
In doing so, you'll
increase your reach
by providing value
to your gamers.
We've created a new loading
UI for launching games
from Google Play Instant.
We think it's much more
appropriate for a gaming
experience.
And users have been telling
us that they love it.
It sometimes takes a little
longer to launch a game
than it is to launch an app.
So it was important for us
to keep users entertained
while a game is loading.
To avoid users abandoning
your experience,
try to get them into the
gameplay as soon as possible.
If it is necessary to
show an additional loading
screen in the game, try to
shorten it as much as possible.
You can load in additional
parts of your game
during runtime using the
Google Play core library.
When prompting users to install
your game or to preregister,
show a button in your UI
that uses the words Install
or Preregister.
In games, it is usually
better to not just
rely on the Download
or Install icon alone.
You can choose to show
the prompt permanently
in your UI between levels
or as part of the main menu.
Whether you choose only one of
these options or all of them,
make sure that your users can
have a great experience even
without installing your game.
Your Instant
experience shouldn't
be reduced to an ad banner.
It is important to save your
users' progress when they play
your game after installing it.
In particular,
their achievements
and their purchases must
not go missing after they've
decided to install your game.
You can use the cookie and
storage APIs to do this.
People will want to
keep the magic battleaxe
that they fought so hard for
against those ugly goblins
in that dungeon.
As it is possible to access
games on Google Play Instant
by simply clicking
a link, some users
will access them serendipitously
or unintentionally.
For those users, it
is important to have
a way back out of the game
if they choose to leave.
Do not disable the
Android Back button
at the bottom of the screen.
It is fine to show
a warning when
it is pressed to alert users
they're about to exit the game.
But it is good
practice not to disrupt
established
navigational patterns.
Google Play Instant
is a fantastic way
for users to share their
gaming experience with friends
and let them try
it out themselves.
In your game, make
it easy for users
to invite others to join them.
Players are much more likely
to join if they're not only
invited by someone
they know, but also get
to try out the experience
before they commit
to purchasing it themselves.
To recap, when designing
a user experience
for your game on
Google Play Instant,
consider the right entry points
and use cases for your game.
Remove any unnecessary latency,
and let your users experience
the game as quickly as possible.
Think about the right
moment in your experience
to prompt for installation
and preregistration.
Make sure your users
maintain their progress
after installing the game.
Don't disable the
Android Back button.
And provide a way for users
to share a game with others.
We believe that games
on Google Play Instant
are a great way to remove
friction for your users.
We can't wait to see what
you will build with it.
You can find everything I
talked about here and much more
on g.co/instantapps.
Also, check out
our recommendations
for building a good user
experience in your Instant
apps.
You can find the link in
the description below.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]